[Music]  [Music]  who you for you who's she who are you  guys what the hell  you know Spencer this is  Jumanji you pick a character and then  you're that person in the game should we  play  [Applause]  my god fridge yeah I'm for who are you  it's me Spencer Martha yeah  I think we got sucked into the game and  we've all become the avatars we chose so  that means Bethany  [Applause]  I'm an overweight middle-aged man this  can't actually be happening guys how are  we gonna get home this is a videocast  which means we all have special skills  [Music]  strengths fearless speed smoldering  intensity damn that is a man right there  I hate this game we don't want to get  stuck in Jumanji we have to help each  other game machine I'm not giving you  there okay I'm still an old fat guy  right I'm afraid so I have to warn you I  think I'm a very strong puncher  [Music]  what is it  [Music]  don't let this new body that you're but  will I'd like to see you try  [Music]